- [Host] So up next we have my colleague
and friend Dhanya Sridhar.
She's an assistant professor
at the University of Montreal
CIFAR AI chair, faculty at Mila.
Her research focus is on explaining why.
She's focused on causality
and machine learning
and working on AI systems,
and she's here to talk about
causality and deep learning.
Take it away, Dhanya.
- [Dhanya] Okay, awesome.
Can everybody hear me.
Okay, fantastic.
Okay, so indeed, today's
talk will be about exploring
the intersection of
causality and deep learning.
So let me just kind of tell
you about the objectives
that I have for us today.
So if there are three
things that we achieve
during the course of this talk,
I would hope that they
are that we all gain
a little bit of familiarity
with the language of causality,
that we get a sense of
where deep learning offers
opportunities to improve
the field of causality,
and then vice versa, as well,
and then finally,
I would also like us to
understand what are kind of unique
challenges that we face,
technical challenges in particular,
when we try to combine deep
learning and causality, okay?
So this is what we're going to try to do.
And to start,
I want to begin with a motivating example
that I hope will illustrate
that we all probably already
have somewhat strong
intuitions about causality.
So to begin with that,
let's pretend like we're
all decision making people
and we want to know how to write
customer service complaints
in order to get quick responses, okay?
So what do we do?
We want to understand how,
we want to build a policy
for how to write complaints
that get fast replies,
so we gather a data set of
customer service complaints
and their labeled response times, okay?
So such a data set exists.
In the US, there's the Consumer
Finance Protection Bureau,
where people can lodge complaints
about a variety of consumer
and financial products,
and they also record how timely
this complaint was resolved.
So yes, this angry complaint
is a real complaint,
so you can have a look at it.
And let's say what we do is
we fit a classifier, right?
So we fit a classifier that takes text,
these complaints as input
and predicts which features
are useful for fast replies.
And let's say what we did
after our analysis is learned
that angry complaints
turned out to be predictive
of fast replies.
So let me ask all of you a
question with a show of hands,
how many of you feel convinced
that you would now just adopt
this policy of writing angry complaints
and emails all the time
to get fast replies?
All right.
Okay, maybe some people just
need to vent their frustration.
That's fine.
But a lot of us had an intuition
perhaps that this analysis
did not answer the question
that we wanted to answer,
which was how should I change my behavior
and expect to see this change in the world
where I get faster replies?
That's a question about
interventions and their effects.
And predictions don't distinguish
these interventional queries, right?
What predictions do
instead is they capture
all possible associations in a system
and they don't distinguish between
the causal impact of a variable
and just associations between variables.
So in this case, for example,
maybe this is the true underlying model,
that there's something
like topics that affect
both whether or not you
write an angry complaint
and how quickly those
complaints are resolved.
So, for example,
we actually found in this
dataset that when the complaints
are about financial products like banks,
the complaints are both angry
and they're actually resolved
at a higher rate of timeliness.
So these kinds of spurious
associations exist
and predictions are not immune
to capturing them, okay?
So we need a language that
allows us to talk about
the effects of making
manipulations to the world.
And that is what causality is all about.
And let me tell you a little
bit about when we see causality
in the real world when we need it,
just to kind of motivate
that this is a topic that is
foundational to science,
to decision-making,
to understanding bias and many more ideas.
So in keeping with the
theme of science here,
so, for example,
when we want to measure the
effectiveness of therapeutics,
when we want to understand, for example,
whether a vaccine
or a new drug actually has
a causal effect on recovery,
this is a causal question
that we need to answer.
In order to gain better understanding
of biological mechanisms,
we need to understand
how molecular variables
have a causal impact on
other downstream pathways
and other macromolecules.
Now, when we come to
decision making, for example,
causality has already been useful as a way
of actually finding evidence of biases.
So, for example,
there was a really interesting
study that looked at
daylight savings time that introduces
a kind of random variation
in when it gets dark
to show that in fact it seems like
there is a racial bias with police stops.
Moreover, it is a useful
language, as well,
to think about mitigating
harm from non-causal
spurious correlations that our large
machine learning systems are
very prone to memorizing.
So, for example,
this is a real prompt that was given to,
I believe, stable diffusion,
and you ask it to produce a
nurse sitting in a white room
and you see that it really
amplifies maybe biases
in our real world, right?
So now you just have a bunch
of female presenting nurses
in this set of images.
And the language that
we need to understand
what differentiates these
kinds of spurious associations
from associations that are
potentially more stable,
causality can provide a very useful one.
In that same vein,
this idea of what remains
stable versus what doesn't
is also a powerful tool
that will be useful
when we think about generalizing
to out of distribution,
so to new distributions that
are not our training data
when we train our deep learning models,
and perhaps these new
distributions are consequence of
unseen interventions
that the world is taking.
So understanding how we can be robust
to those kinds of unseen interventions,
causality once again will
provide a useful framework,
and we'll see this
specifically in this talk.
So now that I've kind of motivated
when causality is applicable,
we've kind of seen that
we already all have
a bit of an intuition,
let's kind of get into the
nuts and bolts a little bit.
So to ground this,
I'm going to present a
causal graphical model here.
And the example,
the running example will
be this clinical setting
where there's a treatment of interest
whose causal effect we're
interested in analyzing.
That will be the receipt of a drug.
We have some variables that
affect the treatment of interest
as well as our outcome of interest,
which will be recovery,
and these variables that
affect both the treatment
and outcome will be the
patient's health status, okay?
So causal models like standard
directed graphical models
tell us how to factorize the
observed data distribution.
They tell us what kinds of
independencies are encoded
in the distribution of
these three variables.
And their sort of superpower, though,
is that they also, using a
shared set of parameters,
they entail what are called
interventional distributions.
So, for example,
this particular interventional
distribution tells us that
what we do is we give every single person
the particular drug, okay?
So we set the random
variable T to value little t,
and therefore there is
no longer a distribution
over this treatment random variable.
It's just a delta spike.
So you can imagine this as
we've decided that no matter
who comes into the doctor's office,
we are going to give
them this therapy, okay?
But notice crucially that
these two different
families of distributions,
they share all other factors, okay?
Everything else remains invariant.
So that is to say, for example,
the biological mechanisms
that drive recovery don't vary
regardless of whether
we give people the drug
or they choose to take the drug, right?
So no matter how the value of t gets set,
this causal mechanism stays
exactly the same, okay?
And to kind of keep going with this,
to illustrate one more
interventional distribution,
we can think of an
interventional distribution
in which we change the causal
mechanism of recovery itself.
So we do some intervention.
Let's say we have a mouse model.
We maybe give the mouse antibiotics
and seed it with different bacteria
just changing its system fundamentally.
Notice that what an
intervention means graphically
is that we sever that
variable's links to its parents,
and that kind of makes sense, right?
We no longer allow that
variable to take on a value
by the natural mechanisms.
We go in and we intervene and
we set it to a constant, okay?
So this is just the,
this is basically in
some sense in a nutshell
all you really need to start
thinking about causality.
So we have this idea of the do operator.
Mathematically what it means
is that we're going to modify
the graph in this particular
way by removing incoming edges.
And then we have this invariance property
where every other mechanism
stays exactly the same
across the family of distributions
that a causal model entails.
That's it.
So now what kinds of questions
can we ask now that we have
this language of do?
So going to this clinical
setting once again,
a very common causal effect
that we often analyze from data
is the average treatment effect.
And what the average
treatment effect is asking us
is the difference in average outcome
between two interventional distributions,
one where you go in and
you give everybody the drug
and one where you go in
and you prevent everybody
from taking the drug, okay?
So, but mathematically
it's not that special.
It's just looking at the
contrast between the means
of two univariate distributions, okay?
But what's special is that these are
interventional distributions
that are defined
after you modify your graph in
the way that I talked about.
Now, we can be a bit fancier.
We can ask about conditional
average treatment effects.
What this is a function.
It takes as well a
variable Z to condition on.
And for every value of that variable,
you can understand the causal effect,
the ATE for that variable setting.
So, for example,
for every single value of
little z, you can have an ATE.
So you get a function
and this function is called
the conditional average
treatment effect or CATE, okay?
So for the rest of this talk,
I'm going to stick with the ATE
just because it's a bit simpler,
but it's conceptually
the same with the CATE.
We want to ask, okay, well,
how do we even draw causal inferences?
Sometimes you can sample from
interventional distributions,
maybe if you can do
experiments like in biology
where you can literally
manipulate the system,
you can sample from these
interventional distributions.
But what if we cannot?
And moreover, in any case,
you can't both simultaneously
give somebody the drug
and not give somebody the drug, right?
So we need a way of doing
inference when we can't actually
sample these interventional
distributions directly.
So our kind of instinct would be, well,
what can we do with the observed
data distribution, right?
Unfortunately, we can't just
look at the correlations
between T, our treatment
of interest, and Y,
because we can see here, right?
There's two pathways
that carry associations
between T and Y.
One is the actual causal effect,
and then the other is this pathway
via the confounding variable Z, okay?
And we say that these Z variables
confound the causal effect.
And so, okay, so what we know
now is observed correlations
are not going to be our answer
to identify the causal effect,
but let's kind of just
take one of the terms
in the average treatment effect.
Let's look at the left term
and let's just break it
down a little bit, okay?
So the first thing we're
going to do is apply
the law of iterated expectation.
The next thing I'm going
to do is just expand out
the outer expectation over
the treatment variable.
And when I do this, I
notice something peculiar,
which is that in the do distribution,
because there's no more randomness
in this random variable T,
because whenever I'm doing T equals one,
T cannot possibly be equal to zero,
the second term just goes away.
And then finally,
because I said that every other mechanism
between the do distribution
and the observed
distribution is conserved,
there's this invariance,
we end up with this
expression at the very end
that's only in terms of the observed data.
So there's a little bit of math here,
but let me just tell you
what the takeaway is,
which is that we can do
the same for the other term
in the ATE,
move things around,
and what we'll get is this
really interesting result
that says that in this
graph when Z is observed,
when the confounders are observed,
the observed data
distribution actually gives us
the causal effect.
There's a way to calculate it
without any interventional samples,
but via this formula
that I just showed you,
which is called causal
adjustment or G formula
or adjustment formula.
It goes by many names.
So this is our first contact
with this idea of identifiability
from non-interventional sources of data.
So there's a way to
calculate causal effects
even if you cannot do those
interventions directly.
But alas, what if Z
was not fully observed?
Then do we still get to apply the formula
and get a unique answer
back for the causal effect?
Unfortunately, no,
because now I'm going to again just write
the adjustment formula,
but expand it a little bit,
and we'll see that this effect is
what we call non-identifiable.
What that just simply
means is that there are
infinitely many choices
that we can pick for P of Z
and also the causal mechanism
that don't change the
distribution of the data at all.
They don't change P of T and Y at all.
That will yield completely
different causal effects, okay?
So unfortunately, when Z is not observed,
we cannot use this
adjustment formula anymore.
But happily, there's
other things we can do
if we can get other kinds of data.
So a common example that
I suspect a lot of you
are familiar with at least
is randomized control trials.
So sometimes what we can
do is randomly assign
the treatment variable
with some probability
that does not depend on the confounder Z.
The most obvious thing to
do is to just flip a coin,
a fair coin,
and give people the drug or
not give them the drug, right?
And this is one of the
driving forces by which we do
causal inference for clinical settings,
for macroeconomics, policy
assessment and evaluation.
This is kind of the bread and butter.
So here, because this randomization mimics
the exact structure of the
interventional distribution,
what we can do is in order to calculate
the causal effect of doing T,
we just have to condition on T
and look at the average value
of the outcome variable, okay?
So that's one thing we can do.
There is a whole field, as well,
on quasi-randomization
where we cannot maybe
directly randomize the treatment variable,
but there is some other
what we call instrument
that induces random variation
in the treatment variable
without actually affecting Y at all.
So you can think of this as another source
of giving you randomization
without you explicitly
randomizing the assignment
of the treatment.
And with IV, instrumental
variables, sorry,
things get a bit more complicated
in how you estimate the causal effect.
So I'm not going to kind of go into
the technical details of that,
but this is a field
that you can read about.
Yes, is there a question?
Yes.
Okay, there's a question
about if these are DAGs
and if we're doing Bayesian inference.
So there's no Bayesian inference
happening here just yet.
So what we're doing here is we have
an underlying graphical model, agreed,
and it's a DAG.
When we write down a causal
quantity that we care about
like the ATE,
we can express those distributions
that we want to sample from, for example,
E of Y do t equals one,
by removing some edges from
the DAG that we began with.
That becomes our new DAG
that we wish to estimate
this quantity in.
And you can't do it literally
by looking at the conditional
distribution in the observed data,
but you can do it with
this adjustment formula.
Okay, good.
So this was when Z was
just not observed fully
and we had to rely on other kinds of data.
But now let me ask a question.
What if the confounders
aren't directly observed,
but we have some other measurements
or some other data that gives us a clue
as to what they are, okay?
So let me motivate that
with a concrete example.
Suppose that in the case of now text,
let's say I want to understand
what is the causal effect
on getting your paper accepted
if you have a theorem in your paper, okay?
So here the treatment of
interest is including a theorem
in your paper or not.
The outcome of interest is
acceptance at a conference.
And here the confounders may be
subject matter of the paper, right?
So what you write about
would obviously affect
both whether or not you
put a theorem in your paper
and also it likely affects
the rates of acceptance
because we know that
differs across fields.
We don't literally get
to observe the subject
of every single paper in our dataset.
But let's say we also
get a paper abstract.
So this text information
clearly carries information
about what the subject is, okay?
So that's a setting that we're in.
And notice there's a key assumption here,
which is that the text we're
going to assume does contain
all of the confounding information.
We can, I'm saying this kind
of in a more informal way.
The paper here that I'm presenting
makes it more mathematically precise.
But suppose that another
way to think about this
is that we could have used the full text
to do that causal adjustment,
but why would we maybe
not want to do that?
It's because the text is
high dimensional, for one,
and it contains a lot
of nuisance information
that is not pertinent to
the causal inference problem
that if we adjust for
our effect estimation
becomes very high variance.
It becomes statistically
inefficient, right?
So what we would like is a
representation of the text.
We would like to use ideally
deep learning methods
to recover some numerical
representation of the text
that contains all of the
confounding information,
but nothing else, right?
So we want to kind of have
minimal confounding representation
that we extract from the text, okay?
So let me kind of build up how we do this
and some intuitions behind the
desiderata that we lay out.
So let's just kind of be
more straightforward and say,
well, what if I just apply
my favorite representation
learning method to the text
and I learn some embeddings
that capture the text well?
Couple things can go wrong, right?
So one thing that can
go wrong is depending on
which objective you use,
this representation that you
learn may fail to recover
all of the confounding information.
Maybe it, whatever objective you set up,
maybe it's a contrastive
objective that prefers to learn
the noisy parts of the text
rather than the confounding parts.
The other thing that can go
wrong is, again, naively,
the representation that
you learn has no incentive
to throw away the irrelevant
information, right?
It's going to learn both the confounding
as well as all the noise.
There's no reason for
it to discard the noise.
So here's the desiderata that we lay out.
First we want to learn a mapping from text
to an embedding that knows how
to reconstruct X well, okay?
So that is going to
encourage it to capture
as much information as possible.
Then we're going to use the
graph structure to regularize.
So what do we do?
We train the representation
to predict both T and Y,
because the confounding
information is uniquely the thing
in this model that it can predict
both the treatment and outcome.
The noise is just not going
to have any information
about the treatment and outcome.
And so what we do is build the system
that has some reconstruction objective
and then has these two prediction terms
to encourage capturing just
the confounding information.
So let me give you,
this is a general purpose framework.
You can slot in your favorite
text representation method,
but we'll give an example here using BERT.
So what we did was we trained BERT to,
we fine tuned BERT, rather,
to predict the treatment label
for every single document
in our corpus
and also the expected outcome,
and we did this for two groups,
the group of documents
that have the treatment,
that have a theorem in them,
and separately the group of documents
that don't have a theorem in them.
So we have three prediction heads
and jointly we continue to fine tune
using the masked token loss,
which in BERT is just a proxy
for reconstructing the text well.
So this way we do this
trade off between learning
as much information as we can
so that we make sure we capture Z
and then throw away
everything that's not Z.
Yeah.
Yeah, the question is about
what if X contains noise?
Doesn't the objective keep the noise?
Well, I mean, of course, indeed,
that's the first desiderata
is indeed to train
to keep as much information
that's predictive of the text as possible.
But the second desiderata
is a constraint that regularizes, right?
That discourages learning anything
that is not predictive of
the treatment and outcome.
So you end up with this
trade-off, of course,
that you have to deal with,
like we often do when we have
a lot of constrained optimization,
but that is a separate problem.
Okay, so unfortunately,
evaluating these kinds of methods is hard
because any causal inference
suffers from the problem
that we typically don't
have for some dataset
the average treatment
effect of the treatment
of interest lying around,
so what we do in this case is
a semisynthetic evaluation.
So we took the period corpus,
which has known paper abstracts.
There's a label for
whether there's a theorem
in the paper or not,
and there's also a label,
there's a covariate for
whether there's a buzzy word
in the title or not, okay?
And we verified that indeed
this buzzy word variable
is predictive of both the theorem
and it is also predictable
by the paper abstract.
So it's clearly correlated
with both of those things.
And what we do is we simulate
an outcome that depends on
both the theorem and
this buzzy word variable.
So in a sense, we create
a confounded outcome,
and then when we go to fit the model,
we don't give it the true confounder Z.
We see how well it can recover that
from the text directly, okay?
So let me just show one
of the top line results
from this paper,
but there's many others in the paper.
So we compare this causal
BERT idea with just an MLP
that takes the text as input
and predicts T and also predicts Y, okay?
And we do the causal effect
estimation in the same way
that we do with causal BERT.
And what we do is we vary the dependence
between the confounder
and outcome with the expectation
as the outcome is super, super confounded,
then it should be harder
to get an unbiased
causal effect estimate.
The ground truth is just the ground truth
causal effect, okay?
So the causal effect is just one.
The unadjusted method just
reports the correlation
between treatment and outcome,
and unsurprisingly, it's
very biased as the dependence
between the confounder
and outcome gets high.
The neural network,
which is doing some adjustment
because it's taking the text as input.
You can think about it
as like the technique
that I introduced as the naive technique
that just doesn't do any
representation learning,
that just tries to do
adjustment with a full text.
And indeed, it does better.
But in this particular experiment,
we see that the causal BERT,
these causally sufficient
text representations
led to more accurate effect estimates.
Throughout our experiments,
we saw this theme recurring,
and of course this is
on semisynthetic data,
but this is kind of giving
some initial promising results, right?
And instead of talking about
more of the results here,
I want to just kind of give the key point,
which is that when we want
to extract confounders
from some high-dimensional
signal like text
or maybe images or medical data,
then the constraint that we
need for deep learning methods
is some constraint that prefers
the confounding information
over other generative
factors that are irrelevant
to the causal problem, okay?
So, so long as we can
separate these two signals,
then deep learning gives us an opportunity
to estimate causal effects.
Of course, some assumptions
have to be satisfied,
there's a caveat, but
there's an opportunity here.
Now, we should ask then, okay,
well, what about if we
want to use representations
as a way of capturing
the causes of an outcome?
What do representations
have to satisfy there?
So let me give a motivating
example for this.
Let's say I wanted to
study the causal effect
of some proteins,
some latent macromolecules
on a disease phenotype of interest.
It's pretty hard to measure protein levels
so maybe what we have access to
is gene expression measurements,
which are going to be, in this case,
a parent of the latent
protein levels, okay?
And we want to ask, can we,
how can we learn a representation
of these latent causes
so that we can then do causal inference
and understand the effects
that they have on this disease?
Let's again, for purpose
of building this up,
start with the most naive idea.
So the first thing that
we may think of is, well,
I'll train a feedforward
neural network to predict
the outcome from some gene
expression measurements.
So here we can think of
the first many layers
of a neural network as
the feature extractor
that tries to recover the
relevant latent causes,
and then I can maybe train
a linear map to predict why.
So here the output of the
feature extractor I will think of
as being my latent, as a proxy,
as a substitute of my latent causes.
And we should ask,
does this work for causal inference?
So let's just think what do the solutions
for this representation look like?
Another way of putting this
is what are all the things
that minimizing this
objective would return?
So suppose the true
model really is linear,
then of course the round
truth representation, right?
The thing that just actually captures Z
and the true linear map W will
minimize prediction error,
that's for sure.
But there's actually going to be
infinitely many other solutions, as well.
So, for example,
all these other solutions
that apply some linear
transformation to the features phi and,
or, sorry, that apply linear
transformation to the true Z
and then undo that transformation,
these are all valid
solutions that minimize
this prediction error.
And we're very likely to end
up with one of these rotated
representations as opposed
to the ground true sets.
So what does that look like?
So let's just expand out what
this AZ term would look like.
It is something that takes
the true latent causes,
the true protein levels, let's say,
and entangles them.
It mixes them with each other, right?
And now let's ask,
can we still do causal inference
with a representation like this?
And it would be fairly clear to see no,
because there's a very big difference
in the causal effect of Z1
and Z1 entangled with all of the other Zs.
So for causal inference, right?
This naive representation
learning doesn't suffice.
Somehow we need extra
constraints to make sure
that the semantics of the
causes are maintained,
and we'll see more what
that means formally
in a second here.
So there's a whole field called
identifiable representation learning
that exactly makes this idea
of preserve semantics precise.
So what we want is to recover
the true latent causes
up to some transformations
that are very benign
that don't affect our causal conclusions.
In that case it would be permutation.
So you can change the
order in which you label
the latent variables or
some rescaling, okay?
So these won't hurt our ability
to do downstream causal inferences.
And so we would like
to get representations
that actually recover the ground truth
up to these transformations.
And that's not, as we saw,
possible with these generic
representation learning objectives.
So what do we need to do?
We often need other kinds of data
or constraints that we use to pin down
the correct representation.
There's a lot of work that has
recently come out around this
that uses data augmentation,
so paired samples of every single image
or text that you have in your corpus,
work that uses temporal data
and constraints on the,
like the latent transition
matrix of an HMM, for example.
There's work that uses multiple
domains, AKA environments,
or multiple tasks.
And there's also work, ours, in fact,
that is one of these that uses constraints
on the decoding function.
So in this case I just had a linear map,
but there can be other decoding functions.
What I'm going to talk about
briefly is a technique that falls
into this multiple environments
line of work that uses
a very particular
constraint based on sparsity
that will give us
identifiable representations.
And I'm going to show a little
bit how actually that will
allow us to do valid causal inference.
So we're going to stick with
this linear outcome model,
but we're going to get data
from many different environments.
So you see I put a plate
around all of this,
which just means that we have
e different environments,
and in each domain or environment
I will sample X and Y.
Z is latent.
So now our model is that
in each environment,
we're going to have some
environment specific
linear coefficients that
map the protein levels
to the disease phenotype Y.
We're going to make a very
specific choice, though,
on how these per environment Ws,
these linear maps relate to each other.
And let me kind of talk you
through that really slowly.
So we're going to assume that
the environments are related
via some known tree.
So you can think of this
as being, for example,
in the biological context,
maybe the tree that encodes for speciation
or the phylogenetic tree, AKA,
or a tree that encodes how
cell types differentiated
to be different from each other.
So what we do is we suppose
that the weights in, let's say,
environment two are the root node weights
plus some delta offset, okay?
So there's a lot of parameter
sharing happening here.
As you go further along in the tree,
so, for example, for W4,
its weights are the root node's weights
plus delta offsets that
account for all the arcs
that led to this particular node.
Now, we make a very, very
specific choice on these deltas.
So these deltas are sparse.
They have to be one sparse, in fact,
which means that another way
of putting this is the value of
a single coefficient can
change and that's it.
Another way of putting
this is the mechanism
that mediates proteins
and disease progression
varies across environments,
but varies sparsely only
along a single dimension.
So now the parameters that we
have to learn are going to be
the root weight, the root node weights,
as well as all of these
offset terms, okay?
And then we'll collect
all of those offset terms
and put it into a matrix capital delta
and we'll call the root weights W0, okay?
So those are the parameters
that we have to learn.
And what are we going to do?
So we call this technique
tree-based regularization
because what it's going to do is,
like our standard
empirical risk objectives,
it is going to minimize
the empirical risk across environments.
So we want to learn weights
that are good at predicting why, right?
That's another way to put it.
But we penalize these offset
matrix to be sparse, okay?
So we add a penalty that
measures the L0 norm
of this delta matrix so that the offsets
that we're learning
are sparse as possible.
So why does this help?
Let's go back to considering
our entangled solution, right?
And remember we said to
minimize prediction error,
what this entangled solution has to do
is undo the entanglement
and then it can compose
that with the kind of
the true weights and offsets.
But the trick here as to
why this L0 penalty helps us
select a good representation
for our purposes is that
notice that this matrix multiplication
of delta times A inverse,
A inverse is not sparse,
it's dense, right?
It's undoing a dense
linear transformation.
Generally this is not
going to achieve a lower L0
than the ground truth sparse solution.
That's the trick here.
So we're adding a constraint
that preferentially
prefers the solutions,
the representations that
we would like to get
as opposed to the linearly
transformed representations.
And so the theorem in fact is
just stated informally here,
is that when we have this
tree-based regularization
with this L0 term,
the solutions that minimize the L0 norm
are the ones that recover the true latents
up to permutation and scaling, okay?
So you may shuffle around,
if originally protein one was protein one
in your learned representation,
you may call it protein three,
but that doesn't really matter.
That's kind of semantics, right?
And the rescaling, as well,
is another transformation
that we're kind of,
it's benign for our purposes.
And now let me kind of
ask this question again.
Does these permutation
invariant representations,
do they really help us
with causal inference?
And so what we did was we simulated data
and what we did was we simulated data
and we fit this model using two things.
One, just a baseline neural
network like I described
that simply takes gene
expression pooled across
all the environments as input,
predicts, learns a representation phi,
predicts Y with a linear map.
And we had the representation
learned via our approach,
and what we do is we use
each of these separately
to estimate the causal effect on Y,
and we also do that with the
ground truth representations,
and we compare the errors,
the differences and
estimates that you would get
via the ground truth
versus our, these three,
these two different
representation techniques.
The caveats here,
we don't deal with things
like unobserved confounding.
We're able to estimate the causal effect
in a very straightforward
way using causal adjustment
like I showed earlier.
And the key takeaway is
that it's kind of very clear
in this matrix that,
or these results tables,
is that the representation
learned by our approach
is able to more or less give
you the same causal effect
that you would've gotten if
you'd used the ground truth,
but this entangled,
this linearly entangled
representation you get when you fit
just a naive neural network
really, really biases
your causal effect estimation, okay?
So again, the takeaway is just that,
contrast this to the previous
world when we were just trying
to extract confounding information.
We didn't care about this identifiable
representation learning, right?
We just cared about
separating the confounders
from everything else.
But now our desiderata is a bit stronger.
We actually need,
in order to do causal inference
where we think of the causes
as being learned via
latent representations,
we have a higher standard.
We need to have these
disentangled representations
that somehow maintains the
semantics of the causes, okay?
Now, I want to kind of
stay within this vein
and ask this question of,
well, how can causal
models help deep learning?
And I alluded to this idea that
when you combine representation learning,
deep learning, and causality,
we may get some nice benefits
for generalizing to out of distribution.
And I want to go back to that
point as my concluding thing.
Let's just remind ourselves the
superpower of causal models,
which is that there's a lot of invariance
that they very nicely encapsulate
where only the variable
that you're intervening on changes,
its distribution changes,
and in this case it changes to a constant,
but every other parameter,
every other conditional
distribution stays invariant.
And in some sense,
this invariance is exactly what
we need when we want to be,
we want to get kind of stable behavior
across domains, right?
We want to use causal mechanisms
to predict as much as possible
because their behavior remains invariant
or the risk that they achieve
will remain invariant.
So let me illustrate this
with a more concrete example.
In this example,
which was taken from a paper
that was using camera traps
to do object detection,
they had this,
they noticed this observation that
when cows are in pasture backgrounds,
this model clearly recognizes
that there is a cow
in the image,
but when there's a cow
frolicking around on a beach,
it notices that there's a
beach and water and seashore,
but it doesn't recognize
that there's no cow
or that there's a cow, right?
So this was the observation that was made.
So it seems like there's
some spurious relationship
between what's predicted
and the background.
So let me just give a twee model for this.
It may be a little bit
contrived, but that's okay.
It's for example's sake.
So suppose that this is what's happening,
that there's a human labeler, right?
How they label is very clearly affected
by what's in the image,
the animal that's in the image.
But let's say they're also affected
by the quality of the image itself.
So if it's really blurry,
it's hard for them to label.
And let's say the quality is,
it confounds, as well, the scene.
So maybe when you're trying
to photograph animals
on a beach,
or if you're photographing
them with snow in a blizzard,
the quality also just
tends to be much worse.
So what we see here,
and let me just kind
of introduce a very key
other assumption, as well.
Suppose that between the training domain
and the test domain, the quality,
the distribution of quality changes.
So in your training data,
let's say you're seeing on average
much more high-quality images.
On your test data,
you're seeing many more
low-quality images.
In this world,
what happens is this particular
conditional distribution,
the probability of predicting
a label given an animal,
this mechanism will remain the same
no matter how P quality changes, okay?
Another way to say this
is that it will achieve
the same risk.
Or another way to say this actually is
that its risk is bound
and maybe the variance of the
label changes a little bit,
but this particular
mechanisms remains robust.
But let's consider the
conditional distribution
of label given scene.
This changes as P quality
changes because this very much,
this association is not causal, right?
Going back to this idea
that causal conditionals
remain invariant, others do not.
There's no guarantee.
And in this case,
this conditional can change arbitrarily
as P quality changes,
meaning that its out of distribution risk
could be really, really arbitrarily bad.
So we would have a preference
to learn the causal mechanisms.
We would have a preference to discover
the causal parents of a variable
and use those conditional distributions
when we do prediction.
Unfortunately, causal
structure cannot be identified
from observations alone,
and the reason for this is
there's nothing separating
just from likelihood alone
this correct causal model
versus this alternate model in which scene
could be thought of as a parent
of label, as well, right?
So this other model in
red is clearly incorrect,
but it has the same exact,
it produces the same likelihood
as the correct model.
And so there's been a lot
of work that talks about
the use of auxiliary data,
in particular some
environment labels once again.
So let's say now we also
label our data from the region
that we get the data from
and let's say region affects the quality
of the images taken.
And we also have this,
so we have this auxiliary region variable,
and now our causal model may be identified
because we notice here that the scene
and region are associated,
but animal and region
marginally are not associated.
There's no pathway
marginally that takes you
from animal to region.
So now there's a signal,
there's an asymmetry that we
can use to constrain learning
so that we learn the
causal parents of label
as opposed to these
spuriously related variables.
And so there's a lot of
work on this subtopic,
and I unfortunately, you know,
would have to spend another
hour to dive into it.
But the key takeaway here is that
there's a nice symmetry
between the invariances
that causal models give us
and how they can be really
useful for predicting
when we use deep learning
methods or any other method.
Unfortunately, there's
a technical challenge,
which is that learning causal
models is not identified,
but with some auxiliary data
and the causal model
can give us constraints
that may help us learn more
robust predictors, okay?
So what I'm going to conclude
with is just a lot of
open problems that I
didn't touch upon today,
but are also just sort of
good areas of future research.
I think when we talk about
reinforcement learning,
there's a lot of work to
do on the perspective of
embodied agents that
interact with the world
and have to do interventions
in order to learn
presumably causal variables
and causal models of the world.
So there's a lot of rich work to do
in combining reinforcement learning
and causal representation learning.
In a similar way,
we want to understand how
causality could actually improve
some of the guarantees of
RL, the robustness of RL.
Another kind of useful thing
about causality is we said
that it helps us predict the
effects of interventions.
And it would be very
interesting to have models
that could predict the effects of
completely unseen interventions, right?
And this is kind of very, very open work.
And then finally, just in terms
of representation learning
and thinking about really
rich models of science
and the world,
there's a lot of latent
variables that are really, really
hard to recover using
representation learning.
So what I call second order variables,
like if you have, for example,
a video or a series of images,
it's not obvious that
we can recover variables
like the acceleration of the objects
or the mass of the objects.
We would need some extra assumptions,
but these kinds of variables
would make our understanding
of the world much richer.
So there's a lot of kind of
really interesting work to do
at the intersection of deep learning RL
as well as causality.
And so that's my talk.
I'm going to conclude,
and I'll just say that
there's a lot of resources
that I flashed by in this talk.
And what I'm going to do to
aid lookup later on is post
all of these to a resource
section on my website
later today, I promise.
So please go have a look
if you want to read about
outer distribution generalization,
identifiable representation learning,
or any of these other topics.
So thank you so much, and
yeah, I'll take questions.